Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and Oscar Isaac
has just been cast as Apocalypse in the next
X-Men Movie.
Originally it was called Age of Apocalypse,
now the movie is just called Apocalypse.
Oscar Isaac in case you forgot is one of the
main cast members of Star Wars Episode 7.
It’s a little too soon to be calling him
the next Chris Pratt but maybe we can think
of him as an evil Chris Pratt.
A small indie actor that suddenly blows up
playing villains in some of the biggest franchises
in history.
To be clear, we don’t know officially what
his Star Wars character is going to be.
The rumors say scoundrel but I’ll talk more
about that during my Star Wars Trailer breakdown
on friday.
Today is all about Mutants.
And we can actually use that word because
this is FOX.
I get so tired of all the legal bullshit with
Fox using the word mutant and Marvel using
the word Inhuman to describe people humans
with special powers.
Whatever, here’s what we know about the
movie so far.
In order of importance to the narrative there’s
Apocalypse, it’s named after him, of course
it’s going to be about his life, then Jennifer
Lawrence’s Mystique and Michael Fassbender’s
Magneto.
All the other young cast members will be back
from Days of Future Past.
The ones that did not die that is.
And the movie will take place in the near
future after the events of Days of Future
Past.
If that was in the 70s, just consider Age
of Apocalypse to be early mid 80s.
The end credits teaser featured Apocalypse
in Ancient Egypt so there will be flashbacks
explaining where he came from.
But the majority of the movie will be in present
day.
When the characters are all adults.
The story was planned to be the next logical
step given the events of Days of Future Past.
So magneto assaults the president on live
television with all the world watching.
He’s taken down, but where do we go from
here.
And what about the other end credits scene
where Wolverine wakes up in the alternate
timeline version of Professor X’s academy.
The future where everyone is still alive?
The timeline is going to get fuzzier, but
it just implies that of course the X-Men will
defeat apocalypse.
The X-Men franchise is such a critical part
of Fox’s earnings as a company, that I don’t
think they’d risk money by leaving things
on a super downer ending.
The safe bet is always to give the protagonists
a big win.
Unless it’s Empire Strikes Back and your
movie is part of a Trilogy.
Which it kind of isn’t, the X-Men Franchise
isn’t really a trilogy right now.
It’s just a new movie every couple of years
that are all loosely connected.
It’s not like Christopher Nolan’s Dark
Knight Trilogy where the beginning, middle
and end are all meticulously planned in advance.
If you haven’t read the Age of Apocalypse
Comic Book Story or seen the animated tv series
adaptation.
As the name implies, it’s kind of like a
Days of Future Past situation where the world
is taken over by Apocalypse with the aid of
his four horsemen and Mr Sinister.
Days of Future Past is all about what the
world would look like if Humanity tried to
eradicate the Mutants, Age of Apocalypse is
the other side of that.
Apocalypse as a character isn’t so much
a believer in Mutant Rights like Magneto,
he preaches Survival of the Fittest.
So if you can vaporize matter with eye beams,
in his eyes, you are deemed more worthy of
the right to live in his new world order.
Because they just did Time Travel in the last
movie, I don’t think they’ll do the exact
same thing again.
So I think they’ll change the comic book
story to eliminate the post-apocalyptic parts
and just keep it mostly in present day.
Like the creation of the Four Horseman and
the X-Men fighting Apocalypse and Mr Sinister
to a standstill.
The movie will probably be just as long as
Days of Future Past in terms of duration,
which is well over two hours, so they’ll
have plenty of time to do a whole side story
for Apocalypse and his four horsemen.
Mr Sinister isn’t confirmed but I really
hope we see him.
And speaking of new X-Men characters, they’re
re-casting Cyclops, Jean Grey and the other
X-Men that did not appear in First Class.
I know they had young Cyclops in Wolverine
Origins, but they’re recasting all those
X-Men.
The First Class actors will still play their
characters.
And then there’s the issue of Channing Tatum’s
Gambit.
He’s getting his own Solo Film after Apocalypse
but he’s supposedly not going to be feature
in the big team up movie.
It’s possible they could tease him, it would
make sense from a marketing standpoint.
But his character isn’t going to be a big
part of the film.
Even though in the comics he did become one
of Apocalypse’s Horsemen.
He was Death, in the original comic that was
Warren Worthington.
Everyone asking about Taylor Kitsch being
bumped from the role.
Yes, I think if John Carter had not of been
such an epic flop he would still be Gambit.
Channing Tatum is guaranteed box office for
Fox though.
I’m going to wait till I see footage to
pass judgement on that.
There are tons of things you can do to get
ready for the
Apocalypse Movie though, first being read
the Original Age of Apocalypse
comic book.
A
lot of aspects of that will be in the movie.
It won’t be a straight up adaptation though.
They changed a bunch of stuff about Days of
Future Past from the comics, so just expect
the same thing to happen with the new movie.
Right now Apocalypse is a big part of the
X-Men Avengers AXIS comic book story, so you
should check that out too.
They did Hellfire Club in First Class and
in the comics Apocalypse meets Mister Sinister
through them, so they could bring the Club
back in the new movie.
Age of Stryfe is a fun storyline.
Right now in the comics the Apocalypse in
AXIS is the clone version.
If you have any other big Apocalypse or Mister
Sinsiter comics you guys want to recommend
just write them below in the comics.
Here’s my big question for you.
Do you think that Fox should join their Fantastic
Four movies with the X-Men Franchise.
Do you think they can pull off the same shared
universe Marvel has?
The odds are against them and there are a
lot of bigger hollywood people that are firmly
against this type of shared universe stuff
just because it places a lot of restrictions
on what stories they can tell.
It’s the difference between doing whatever
you want with a group of characters, versus
being forced to write within the canon created
by other directors and writers.
Regardless of whether you like what they did.
Right now I kind of like that only Marvel
is doing it, I don’t think I’d want to
see everyone else do it too.
Please leave your requests for other X-Men
Bonus Videos in the comments and big reminders,
Star Wars Trailer Breakdown coming this friday,
be sure to subscribe to get it.
Tonight I’m posting my Walking Dead Q&A
and then hopefully by tomorrow morning I’ll
have finished my Gotham Finale video.
Lots of cool stuff happening right now.
In case you haven’t seen them yet, I have
new mobile links up here.
They’re the same as my links over here.
Same thing.
Right now click here to learn all about the
Star Wars Episode 7 Trailer and click here
for my Days of Future Past Review.
I really need to make an X-Men Playlist.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives everybody!